Hello everybody, Dr. Kevin Connors here, a quick little video about dairy and cancer.
Should cancer patients be using dairy products?
Well, first we have to ask, should anybody be using dairy products?
Is milk really natural?
Well, in one sense, it is.
It can be.
It depends on the count, depends on the farm, depends on how it's processed.
There can be beneficial uses of dairy, so I am not across the board and dairy, so let's
make that perfectly clear.
The problem is that as our dairy products that we get today, good for you or bad for you,
dairy products that you buy in the store are not acceptable, basically, across the board.
Anything that is pasteurized, that's the big thing, that's the harmful thing.
There's a lot of studies that are out there that the probiotics in, naturally, prevent
the dairy products can be very beneficial.
Here's one study that helps decrease the proliferation, the growth of colon cancer cells.
The problem is that it's the dairy itself, that is the issue.
When you pasteurize it, you decrease that fermentation process because you kill all the good bacteria
and enzymes that have the ability to ferment.
That's why it has a longer shelf life.
That's why it's safe according to the FDA because it doesn't have any bacteria in it.
Well, it's the bacteria in the dairy and the enzymes in the dairy that is actually the good
part for you, so they're destroying the things that are good for you.
Don't be fooled thinking that I'm drinking dairy and eating cheese and drinking milk in order
to have calcium.
That is just absolutely ridiculous.
You get your source of calcium from your green leafy vegetables.
How do you think the cow is good calcium?
You don't get calcium from your dairy.
That's not bad for you.
There's a lot of studies that dairy can subject increases bone disease and cancer because of
the calcium.
It's a huge increase in prostate cancer greater about a dairy that you drink because of the
calcium that's in there.
It's not a good source of calcium.
It leads to prostate cancer at heart disease, so that's a different presentation.
But pasteurization really does the harm of the milk.
You can't argue that it kills the bacteria there.
Boy, you're not going to die of ecoli by drinking pasteurized milk.
That's fantastic.
But then why would you drink pasteurized milk?
There's no nutritional value.
It destroys the milk.
The hormones in the milk are so dangerous.
Even if you buy a horrible, free dairy products, it's still the other hormones that are given
to cows.
The antibiotics that are given to cows, the chemicals that are in the milk, most cows are just
not a true natural breed anymore.
They've been so inbred to make their bags huge so that they can produce gallons of gallons
of milk a day.
They're just not natural animals.
Almost all the big dairies that produce milk that you're buying in the store, those cows
never go outside, never.
It's just not a natural phenomenon to be raising animals and that you're drinking the milk
for those animals.
It's just horrible for you.
I love this pizarro comic right here because that is so true.
It's affected us horribly.
It's very bad.
Don't drink milk.
Intestinal cancer rates, here's just one picture.
I could have pulled up a whole bunch of different pictures of this, different types of cancer,
but this intestinal cancer was just one and they're all very much the same.
They increase about an animal product that a person eats and this talks about country by
country.
It's just a straight scale.
These like Colombia that have a very low consumption of animal products have the lowest intestinal
cancer in all different cancer rates and you go up to dead bark which is a very high animal
consumption product country has the highest intestinal cancer rate.
It's just a one-for-one scale.
It goes up.
It's just crazy.
So dairy is one of those.
When we look at a cancer patient, understand, I know this presentation is great out to people
who will never be by patients, but when we look at a patient, we test them for dairy.
It's dairy and issue, so dairy is not an issue in every cancer, so let's make that perfectly
straight.
But dairy is a mucus form, it doesn't give us really any nutritional value if it's pasteurized.
B, the mucus forward increases other issues, the ability for bad bacteria to grow.
Better source of the fermentation like in that previous slide where the fermented dairy
products are good for you is to use water kefir.
You can use the same fermentation process and get all those probiotics that you would get
from a dairy kefir.
I'm born and raised in Minnesota in Wisconsin, so I love dairy.
It is a craving for me.
It's an addiction for me, so we do have dairy in our house, but we try to limit it.
It's just an overconsumption of it is very harmful in the long run.
So we use substitutes.
Now with this picture here, it shows almond milk, soy milk, soy products, rice product,
rice, dream, rice, milk products.
I would recommend almond milk, I would not recommend soy milk, I would not recommend rice
milk.
I know I show the picture here because I want you to see this is what you're going to see
when you go into the grocery store.
The biggest one that I recommend is coconut milk, so drink coconut milk, almond milk, hemp
milk.
Those are really the substitutes if you want to have a glass of milk with something.
This picture shows different benefits of different products that are out there on the
right there.
Problem with soy is that this is not a fermented soy milk, so that you have hormonal issues with
the soy.
So I do not recommend using soy milk.
Problem with the rice milk is that it typically uses an oriental rice, which is very high in
arsenic, so that's very dangerous to you.
We used to drink a lot of rice milk in our house years ago until we discovered that information.
Coconut milk is your best source, almond milk is another good source, hemp milk is a very
good protein, so those are the things to look for.
There's not a lot of good cheese substitutes out there that really tastes like cheese if
you're used to good Minnesota or Wisconsin cheese, but just decreasing those out of your
diet, you're going to notice a lot of increased health benefits.
All right, hope this was beneficial.